in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 13th, on which we commemorate, the reading for
commemoration of the 4th Ecumenical Council in Calcedon on the Sunday between the 13th and
the 19th of July.
On the Sunday between the 13th and the 19th of this month, we celebrate the memory of the
Holy and God-bearing fathers of the 4th Ecumenical Council in Calcedon.
The 4th Great and Holy Ecumenical Council, which met in Calcedon in the year 451, brought
together 600 fathers, mainly from the Eastern Dioceses.
With their head were Saint Anatolios of Constantinople, the legates of Saint Leo, Pope of Rome,
Bishop Pascasinos and Boniface the Presbyter, Maximus of Antioch and Juvenal of Jerusalem.
This assembly, the greatest the church had known until then, had been convoked by the
devout emperor Marcian and Empress Polcaria in order to re-establish the peace and unity
that had been troubled since the false council of Ephesus in 449 and to condemn the heresy
of Utiches.
After the 3rd Ecumenical Council in the year 431, partisans of the theological traditions
associated with Alexandria and Antioch, had with difficulty come to an agreement on a formula
of faith concerning the union of the divine and human natures in Christ.
The fragile agreement, however, was soon disrupted by the activities of a Constantinopolitan
Archimandrite named Utiches, who advocated an extreme interpretation of the Christology
of Saint Cyril.
Utiches was connected to powerful figures in the court and had assisted Saint Cyril in
the successful prosecution of the 3rd Council.
However, in his desire to extirpate all traces of Nestorianism, Utiches maintained
that, after the incarnation, the two natures of Christ could no longer be distinguished
from each other, because Christ's human nature had somehow been absorbed by his divinity.
Whereas Nestorius had divided and separated the two natures, Utiches, whose pride prevented
him from understanding the truth, which is the royal road running between two extremes,
fell into the opposite heresy and spoke of a mixture or fusion of the two natures resulting
in a single nature, namely the divine one.
From this point of view known as monophysitism, it can only be concluded that such a savior
is not truly of the same nature as the Father, or else incapable of communion with humanity.
The heretical nature of Utiches' teachings, which undermined the mystery of salvation,
were detected by Osevious of Dorileum, after which a local council was convened in Constantinopolitan
people, under the Presidency of St. Flavian, which condemned the Archimandrite in the year
448. Utiches was not slow in calling upon his supporters in the government, and thus succeeded
in turning the situation to his advantage. After a violent intervention by Dioscarus, Archbishop
of Alexandria, at the Robert Council in Ephesus, which took place in April of 449, Utiches
was declared innocent, and Flavian was deposed, and soon died from the ill-treatment that had
been inflicted on him. Following the sudden death of Theldosios II, who had supported
Utiches, Marcian and Pulcheria were called on by Pope Leo and all the Orthodox to put right
the injustice and re-establish peace through an ecumenical council. A new council was therefore
convened, and initially met in Nysia, in September 451, but was relocated to Calcedon and finally
to the Church of Saint Ephemia, which was able to accommodate the large assembly of bishops.
In the course of 16 sessions, held from 8 October to 1 November, the council fathers dealt
with a number of important matters. In the first place, they condemned the Robert Council
of Ephesus and deposed Utiches and Dioscarus, after which they posthumously rehabilitated Flavian.
They subsequently reiterated the condemnation of Nistorius that had been pronounced by the
Council of Ephesus and devoted themselves to a detailed condemnation of the monophysitic
Christology of Utiches, using the same method of conciliation and synthesis as that used
by Saint Cyril and John of Antioch in the years 433. The fathers succeeded in reconciling
the respective points of view of Alexandria, Antioch and Rome, and brought to completion the
work of the third ecumenical council by giving precise definition to the dogma of the
person of Christ the Savior. When they had finished examining the arguments
of Utiches in the light of the Holy Scriptures and the decisions of the preceding councils,
the fathers unathematized anyone who added to or detracted from anything in the faith
as defined by the first three ecumenical councils. Pope Leo was hailed as a pillar of Orthodoxy
and his letter to Flavian provided an important basis for the council's definition of faith,
which was solemnly read in the presence of the Emperor at the sixth session on the 22nd
of October. Following the Holy Fathers, we all, with one voice, confess our Lord Jesus Christ,
one and the same Son, the same perfect in Godhead, the same perfect in manhood, truly God
and truly man, the same consisting of a reasonable soul and a body of one substance with the Father
as touching the Godhead, the same of one substance with us as touching the manhood, like us in all things
apart from sin, begotten of the Father before all ages as touching the Godhead, the same in the last
days for us and for our salvation, born from the Virgin Mary, the Filthocals as touching the manhood,
one and the same Christ, Son, Lord only begotten to be acknowledged in two natures without confusion,
without change, without division, without separation. The distinction of natures being in no way abolished
because of the union but rather the characteristic property of each nature being preserved and concurring
in one person and one epostasis, not as if Christ were parted or divided into two persons, but one
and the same Son and only begotten God, word, Lord Jesus Christ, even as the prophets from the beginning
spoke concerning Him and our Lord Jesus Christ instructed us and the nice scene creed of the Fathers
was handed down to us. The Emperor asked the Council Fathers if they approved the definition
at which they all cried out. We all believe thus, one single faith, one single judgment,
we are all of the same opinion, we have all signed in agreement, we are all Orthodox,
this is the faith of the Fathers, this is the faith of the Apostles, this is the faith that has saved
the world, God will give peace to your reign, Marceon, the new Constantine, and Pulcaria, the new Helena,
you are the torches of the Orthodox faith, your life is the security of all, your faith is the glory
of the churches. By this definition of faith, unique in its depth and precision, the Holy Fathers
confessed the true union of the two natures, divine and human, in the unique person of the word of
God, thanks to the faith of Calcedon, which was given further explanation by such Fathers as Saint
Maximus the Confessor and Saint John Damocene. We, the Orthodox, understand that it is by living
in Christ the God-man, that we can be united with God. It is through Christ that we grow in likeness
to God, without loss of our natural identity. Thanks to the grace of the Holy Spirit,
the unconfused union of divinity and humanity in the apostacies of Christ becomes the foundation
for the Christian's unconfused union with God. The aim of the church, which itself is Christ
our God dwelling among us to the end of time, is to lead us to the measure of the stature of the fullness
of Christ, which is humanity's full participation in divine life. All things come from and lead to
the person of the Savior, and in him all things are thianthropic. Dogma, morality, asceticism, prayer,
liturgy, sacred art, and music, sacred architecture, and so on. In Christ all things are human,
palpable, and historic, and at the same time fully divinized by the energy of the Holy Spirit,
so that it is truly Christ who lives in each one of his members and in all the manifestations of
his mystical body. For Orthodox Christians, the God-man defined by the Council of Calcedon
is the supreme value and ultimate criterion of the truth. For it is in him and through him that we
have access to God and acquire the dignity of sons. In the remaining sessions, the Council
fathers dealt with questions of order and ecclesiastical discipline and all together promulgated 27 canons.
To these they appended a decree confirming canon three of the second ecumenical council
and conferred on the sea of Constantinople as the capital of the Empire, the second place after Rome
with patriarchal jurisdiction over the dioceses of Asia, Pontus, and Thrace, and also the Christian
communities outside the Empire. Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God
have mercy on us and save us.